inspirent des éclairs de génie.
JEANNOT PAINCHAUD président,
chef direction Cirque Éloize
- Je suis venu un soir chez mon,
Louis Painchaud. Puis je lui ai
dit : "hdit : "hdit : "hey on f,
puis j'aimerais ça trouver un
nom des îles." Louis c'est un
ça le cirque Éloize." J'ai dit :
Éloize? Il dit : bien oui,
des éloizes, des éclairs
de chaleur le mot acadien.
J'ai dit : bonne idée ça!
- Ce soir-là, Jeannot Painchaud
s'est fait sur cesit sur cesit e
promesse qui a changé sa vie.
- Je suis monté un soir de pluit
là que je me suis fait comme
une promune promune promune proe
projet-là et de me lancer
à fond là-dedans.
- Le fondateur du cirque Éloize
a écoutédécidé ddécidé ddécidé r
partir à la conquête du monde.
Et les vents étaient favorables.
En près de 30 ans, 5 millions
l'une des 6 000 représentations
que le cirque a donné dans
600 villes à travers le monde.
Mais les deux dernières années
lui soufflait que le temps étai.
- L'idée de revenir, tout à
d'important aux Îles, c'est
assez puissant émotionnellement
je dirais. (rire)
- Et dans la vie, il y a
des petits miracles. Jeannot
à deux pas de la maison où il a
grandi, où son père a vécu
et son grand-père avant,
- Quand j'ai appris que l'église
t une nouvelle vocation
ça a été...
presqu'une révélation.là qu'estt
"Au pied des demoiselles".
Un centre de création
et de diffusion de 17 milliode a
une trentaine d'un
d'hébergement, un gymnase, une
salle de yoga, un
café, des résidences d'artistes
et une salle de spectacle de 400
places dans l'anci
C'est l'architecte Marilène
Blain-Sabourin, une ancienne
du cirque du soleil, qui a étéar
les plans.
MARILÈNE BLAIN-SABOURIN
architecte
- Il y a un paysagles, qui est e
par la vie insulaire. Donc c'est
important de s'intégrer dans
le paysage qui existe.
♪ ♪ tinue!
- La première phase :
rsion de lrsion de lrsion de lre
en salle de spectacle pour
accueillir "Entre Ciel et Mer,"r
les arts du cirque, mais aussile
conte. Avec la participation
de Cédric Landry, un autreot.ot.
CÉDRIC LANDRYconteur
- On est un peuple de conteurs,
c'est sûr. Commeregarde la mer
ici, c'est la mer à perte de
vue. Quand on voit rien on voit
loin, c'est-à-dire que c'est
comme unissements)
- Et samedi, à la grande
première, les spectateurs sont
ressortis émerveillés.
du coin, est vraiment...
sente les Îles.
- Ça réveille le village.
ça fait que le village estrévei.
- Jeannot Painchaud et le cirque
spectacle créer une nouvelle
tradition madelinienne et
un attra
les nombreux touristes qui
viennentdes beautés
de l'archipel.
Ici Nabi-Alexandr